I was actually using heroin and
methamphetamine which is pretty much the
ends of the drug spectrum the worst you
know the worst drugs that you could get
out there I first picked up my first
drug when I was 12 years old I found
cocaine and mix it with alcohol and then
I found the needle and that's when I
gave up everything else
the last thing I remember was I was in a
Walmart parking lot and I was kind of
skating around then I just everything
went black when I woke up I was being
put into an ambulance on a stretcher had
overdosed on heroin so my mom went
online and she got the American
addiction centers and within probably
that same day I started getting phone
calls from the people from the American
addiction center trying to you know
suggest I go to treatment American
addiction centers was founded in 2011 by
Michael Cartwright I've been passionate
about this for 23 years addiction came
this close to taking my life many many
people helped me overcome my disease now
I'm proud to help others overcome their
disease the company has eight facilities
nationwide and treats more than 5,000
people every year last October it became
the first addiction treatment business
to go public why go couple I go back to
nineteen sixty-nine in the 1970s wadded
hospitals go public you know originally
the hospital system was localized and
Along Came HCA and said you know what we
need to standardize how hospitals are
delivering cater I think that the entire
drug and alcohol treatment center we
need to set a standard of care many
times these treatment centers are in
homes their own apartment buildings I
think what you'll see over the next 20
years with American addiction centers
and others is that you'll see it be much
more professionalized in hospital style
campuses or much nicer facility well how
do you do that you need capital
it's a pretty large industry that we
think we can grow into and I don't feel
like that there's a large organization
that really carries that torch right now
American addiction centers raise 75
million dollars in its initial public
offering cartwright wants to use that
capital to fund a nationwide expansion
creating the industry's biggest national
brand when you're talking about the
boutique high-end treatment that you
would see in Malibu I personally think
that it should be done in a facility
more like a hospital I think if you take
a look at what we have at the greenhouse
in dallas texas you would see more of
what i'm thinking you have it's just
serene right you can do outside groups
and the clients enjoy it
you
no one would question that if my
grandmother had cancer that we treat her
in a beautiful facility with good
quality linens and good quality food yet
a drug and alcohol person you ought to
put in a cot in the local mission I do
still think that there's a prejudiced
around this being a moral issue versus a
disease when I came here they have a set
schedule every day you get up you know
you have breakfast time and then you go
to your counseling group that actually
started the basis of my recovery because
the first step is to communicate with
other people it's one day at a time
though right you need a game plan to
stay sober I mean people are going to go
back into a safe environment I'm scared
I'm scared to go back
as I know for sure I'm sorry I'm scared
to go back because my voice is a heroin
addict ever covering hair on having he
has a two-year-old daughter and like how
do you keep yourself straight when
someone isn't straight the ones that
make a solid plan and stick to it
they're more likely to stay so clean and
so I believe in the link this today
concept so much that if somebody stays
at one of our facilities for 90 days
they can come back for free they ever
relapse I'll pay for it
I'm not at this for just a year or two
or quarter by quarter i think that the
public shareholders won't want us to be
good stewards with their capital they're
going to want us to grow as cartwright
grows the company he'll now be subject
to tough scrutiny finding the balance
between making a profit and still
delivering the best quality kid I would
be shocked if people don't accept the
fact that we grow at a reasonable pace
some years and then we grow at a fast
pace other years but I think the main
thing they should be concerned about is
are we delivering good quality hair
customers we're trying to help people
achieve long-term sobriety
we cannot control addiction we cannot
control who is ready to stop and who is
not I've been sober for 16 months my
family is so proud of how good I'm doing
I got to a point with them where I
thought that they would never even want
to you know see me again or be around me
I've been clean for over 16 months my
future is limitless
you